games aren't only a form of
entertainments they're a form of
escapism giving us a chance to explore
whole new worlds filled with enemies to
challenge us where we get to be the hero
or the villain we can level up new
skills unattainable in the real world it
allows us to feel the thrill of being
someone else and of getting to know or
fight rich and diverse characters or
even to work hard for a small town as a
regular citizen in order to pay off your
mortgage yep
I'm talking about Animal Crossing this
is a game that's build up a dedicated
following even though it lacks a clear
goal hair progression enemies and most
other mechanics that have become
ingrained into gaming culture
[Music]
I remember getting a Nintendo DS from
none other than father Christmas himself
and actually the box was wrapped inside
of a cereal box so I undid the wrapping
to find a box of cereal given to me as a
Christmas present
but actually no it was a hidden Nintendo
DS and yes my mother is a comedic genius
during this time simulation games such
as Nintendogs and Harvest Moon became
quite popular and I was in love with the
idea of forming relationships with
adorable pixels when I was gifted my
Nintendo DS it did come with Nintendogs
and I very much enjoyed my routine of
walking petting playing and washing my
dogs on a daily basis however I found
that this mundane routine got very samey
and I eventually got bored Animal
Crossing however became so much more
than its seemingly repetitive gameplay
loops and it's mundane goals in fact I
believe that it helped me see some
really hard times in my life which I
will talk about later on in this video
so for those of you who are wondering
why there's such a hype around Animal
Crossing and how such a simplistic game
charmed the hearts of many then
hopefully I can shed some light on this
today in this video and if you like me
are already charmed by Animal Crossing
then hopefully you'll enjoy a nostalgic
trip down animal Crossing's history and
my own experiences with the game so
here's a quick explanation about what
you can expect when playing an Animal
Crossing game you basically arrive in a
town inhabited by anamorphic creatures
you're new in the town and for some
reason you always decide to travel there
with empty pockets no money I don't know
why but you do
however the lovely mr. Tom Nook will
offer you a place to stay but oh wait
he's not that kind this puts you in his
debt leaving you to do petty tasks for
him and the villagers to earn money and
repay your mortgage along the way you
get to know the town's inhabitants watch
them come and go help reshape the town
buy clothes and furniture and collect
bugs and fish to be displayed in the
museum and enjoy the seasonal and
real-time based events that happen in
the quaint adorable town that is yours
you also get to name that town so so
it's your town why is a game about
paying back debt so much fun well I'm
gonna be honest here for some people it
simply is not fun this game is something
slightly different it doesn't really
have a final conclusion doesn't have any
epic boss battles yeah none of that here
if you love that then maybe you won't
find this fun maybe but maybe you will
because it offers something different
Animal Crossing is honestly one of the
handful of games that I paid at such a
young age that helped me view my own
life slightly differently it reminded me
that there's beauty in even the simplest
of things and you can find happiness in
these simple beauties once I thought I
had learnt the game and its core game
loops I was constantly surprised by
little secrets within the game itself
such as such as floating balloons
hoarding pleasure why can't I say this
line such as floating balloons holding
presents golden bells hidden within
rocks new guests visiting the town and
even Rossetti himself shouting at me
when I had forgotten to save the game
but oh my gosh
maybe my battery just died I did not
mean to save the game not on purpose and
it's please just stop
because I just want to play the game and
you just keep going on and on and on and
I understand you're angry just please I
did not mean to I were that II I
remember excitedly sharing these
findings with my friends and then
sharing to me what they had found in a
town and that just made me even more
excited to go back and play the game
it's pretty cool how we could find these
secrets and talk about them outside of
the game as well and this is where I
just have to go on a little rant and say
games are not what it used to be the
Internet spoils all of these secrets now
it's so hard to try not to find out any
spoilers or any secrets before playing a
game but if you do and you manage to
find it all by yourself it's the most
magical feeling please don't let the
internet ruin that for you okay I'm
sounding super old bells go back to the
script these small details help to make
the world feel alive as everything felt
connected in a way if I hadn't heard of
a game feature from my friends I would
probably have heard it from one of their
towns folk because rumors were prevalent
in that game they would talk about other
towns fault but they would also talk
about the world of them that you were
all living in and how they heard rumors
about specific people coming to the town
or specific things happening in the town
and it kind of felt like myths were
being created by hearing about these
mechanics as rumors it made everything
feel a lot more mysterious and made
these surprises even more rewarding once
you had found them I remember
specifically running to the towns person
who had told me about the floating
balloon in the sky when I had finally
found one I shot it down I wanted to
tell this person that they were correct
in the rumor that they'd heard and that
I actually witnessed it myself however I
was kind of disappointed when this
action was not recognized by that towns
person no ultimately this might have
been pretty disappointing because I
didn't get the recognition that I was
hoping for but it shows you how I'm
sit I was in the game and how I honestly
felt like I knew these animals and they
knew mean that's what Animal Crossing is
all about it's about community it's
about getting to know the town and the
townspeople so much that they welcome
you into that town and you finally end
up feeling like you belong there and I
guess this is as close to an end goal as
you will get playing a game like animal
crossing with side goals like paying off
Tom Nook collecting all there is to
collect extending your house being side
missions along the way and as I said
previously I understand that this may
not be for everyone if you want a game
with a clear ending and a clear player
progression then perhaps this game isn't
for you but I believe that this game has
so much more to offer than just
entertainment I personally found that I
started to play this game at the perfect
time
I've always found changed difficult
being a typical tourist and when I was a
child like most children my parents
decided to split up leaving me having to
adjust with new people being introduced
into my life and others not being around
as often alongs like this I was also
getting used to a newer school
environments and less a minute
school is not an amazingly stable time
friends would come and go there was
bullying there was teachers being
annoying school is just we can just
forget that part of our lives okay yes
so with all of this going on I would
turn to Animal Crossing as my main
source of stability ideas if I needed it
I knew that KK Lila would be there every
Saturday at 8 p.m. no matter whose house
I was in or what's the emotions of the
environment I was living in where like
there would always be happy friendly
smiley towns Falk to greet me whenever I
needed them and there were always my
daily tasks to keep on top of such as
pulling out weeds if I wanted my town to
stay exactly how I wanted it because I
was in control of that town when I felt
like I had no control in the world
around me because let's face it when you
were a young teen or 10 11 year olds you
already have much control in what's
going on in your life so animal crossing
you you can control the animal crossing
it taught me how to deal with my own
insecurities of forming connections
because I got to form connections with
these pixelated anamorphic adorable
creatures including my very favorite who
is a grumpy pig called Rasha and for
some reason I felt like I resonated with
this grumpy ass thing talking to these
animals allowed them to get closer to
you they would actually share more
personal information the more that you
spoke to them and sometimes it would be
quite
sad information they would open up to
you about personal things and talk to
you about them feeling or different
types of emotions not just happiness
also sadness or annoyance or anger
this made the townspeople feel alive
feel like they actually had a
personality that I could connect with
and therefore when the day came that I
loaded up my animal crossing town and
saw that Russia had left to move to
another town
it was quite Sodom I'm not gonna lie
don't laugh at me it was sad call me
silly but I was generally upsetting
because he had even given me a picture
of him as a present to put into my house
which is something that the townspeople
will do when you've reached peak
friendship so I guess that's kind of a
player progression in itself it took me
a while to get used to playing the game
again without his cranky nature and
awesome personality just kind of
crashing and in amongst the more peppier
people within my town which also makes
the town feel so alive because there's
so many different types of personalities
all that's how it felt but I digress
ultimately what I'm trying to say is
that this game helped me get over my
fear of being left because the town's
folk no matter how close to them you
were some of them would just leave but
then they would get replaced by new
characters for you to get to know and
just because they laugh did not mean
that I stopped playing Animal Crossing
it was just part of the experience of
Animal Crossing just like it's part of
the experience of real life
be believed new people come that's so
gay okay this is getting pretty cheese
now so I'll carry on once new leaf came
out I didn't have the 3ds either but I
was in a different part of my life I was
a lot older I was only a couple of years
away from thinking about whether I was
gonna go to university or whether I was
going to leave town and start an
adventure of my own called my career
and I guess I just didn't need animal
crossing and the way that I needed it
when I was younger hence why I say that
this game is not for everyone but for
those of you who need it it's there for
you and the honesty believes that it's
changed my view on life in a positive
way but with this in mind I am so
excited for Animal Crossing new horizons
I actually moved to a small town myself
last year I'm still here right now so
it's kind of like I've been playing my
own game I'm all crossing in the real
world and I can't wait to play this new
game with the new friends that I've made
here but also the old friends that I
don't get to see very much anymore I
can't wait to whack them with nets and
dig little holes outside of their
buildings that they can't move anymore I
wonder if I wonder if that will still be
the case I think I'll have to trick them
into making me the best friend so I can
use these things in their towns and this
won't be Animal Crossing video if I
don't even mention the wonderful
soundtrack that this game has bought for
us I still listen to this music to this
day and no matter what my mood is it's
so chill relaxing and very endearing and
to say thank you for you putting up with
me and my rumbles I've put a link in the
description to an animal crossing google
chrome plug-in and no I'm not sponsored
but I just wanted to share this with you
it's a plugin that when you enable it
plays Animal Crossing music in real time
just like it does in the video game and
yes it does include cake a slider songs
every Saturday 8 p.m. until 12 p.m. so
you
welcome Oh also it's Bree so you don't
have to pay for it
and yeah it's awesome I listen to it all
the time it helps me a lot
studying and working and just when I
want to chill out on a day off so have
you played animal customer for if nots
are you going to play it or are you so
quite confused about why people enjoy
such a simplistic game and if you have
paid Animal Crossing before do you love
it just like me if so please do tell me
why in the comments below do you hate it
maybe possibly I mean I can't imagine
people hating it but if you do let me
know why I'd be very intrigued anyway
thanks again for listening to my rambles
and I hope you enjoy the game if you are
like me and have it on pre-order have a
lovely day everything bye
[Music]